bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
football grosse désillusion pour les
clayes-sous-bois les cuisines les
clients se sont inclinés 4 à 3 contre
caen à domicile au 6e tour de la coupe
gambardella le petit poucet français de
l'épreuve est donc éliminé de la coupe
de france des moins de 19 ans l'eau
résumé à suivant quelques instants
handball plaisir a été tenu en échec par
wei ma maison à l'occasion de la 9e
journée du championnat de prénationale
les deux équipes se sont quittées sur un
score de 21 partout des réactions dans
ce magazine dakar 2010 est nous avons
auprès tristan couedel dans son garage
le pilote hesdinois et s'élancera sur
cette course mythique 2 janvier prochain
ce sera son troisième dakar en près de
20 ans gros plan à présent sur les
principaux résultats du week-end
[Musique]
on commence ce magazine par du football
et une défaite qui restera dans les
annales yvelinoise en coupe gambardella
les clayes-sous-bois ont été éliminés au
6e tour de l'épreuve ce dimanche les
clients perdus contre caen à domicile
dans un match spectaculaire qui s'est
soldé par un score de 4 à 3 les images
sont signés à nicolas d'ambri les
clayes-sous-bois sorte de la coupe
gambardella la tête haute les bleus se
sont inclinés contre caen terme d'un
match très offensif pourtant ce 6e tour
de la coupe de france des moins de 19
ans avait très bien débuté avec un but
du milieu offensif nicolas fadi en
première période
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au retour des vestiaires les christian
baissé de rythme encaissé trois buts en
sept minutes avant de réagir sur penalty
la fin de match est équilibré les deux
équipes trouvent le chemin des filets
score final 4 à 3 la victoire logique
pour eux
oui et non parce qu'en première mi temps
ils ont énormément d'occasions il reste
énormément des 0 à la mi temps les a
prévenus on leur a dit attention ils ont
eu énormément d'occasions et ne pas
cadrer et en dynamitant sa part donné
trop de relâchement dans le temps
faibles c'est là où on a pris le but
et voilà après on a vu on a repris le
contrôle du ballon on a remarqué mais
trop tard malgré la défaite plusieurs
joueurs se sont révélés pendant la
partie c'est le cas de thé au maréchal
surnommé le temps d'un après midi thé ou
neuer en référence au gardien champion
du monde allemand très bon gardien
aujourd'hui qui est très bon toujours et
aujourd'hui je suis fier de lui parce
que ça faisait attrait depuis l'année
dernière que je l'avais eu 17
j'attendais un très grand match de lui
un match 100% parce qu'il me fait
toujours des matches à 40% des parades
décisives qui ont enflammé le public du
stade beltramini plusieurs centaines de
supporters avaient fait le déplacement
pour voir la rencontre et encourager les
joueurs on est fiers représentent les
tous bois on se connaît dans les cent
soixante quatre meilleures équipes et de
france en sachant qu'elle n'a plus de
2000 ou alors même quand on repartira
ils pourront dire que les
clayes-sous-bois voilà s'apprête à un
match facile
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle campagne en gambardella pour
les clayes-sous-bois il faudra se
reconcentrer dès le week-end prochain
sur le championnat
les siens sont actuellement deuxième de
2e division de district
bravo clés sous pour leur parcours qui
restera dans les mémoires
on passe maintenant championnat de
handball en prénationale masculine pas
de vainqueur pour le choc entre wade et
plaisir les deux équipes co leader avant
la rencontre ont concédé le match nul à
21 partout lors de cette 9e journée un
résultat quasiment inespéré pour les
plaisirs aux as qui étaient menés de dix
buts en début de match on écoute les
réactions au micro de nicolas d'enlever
ses très mitigé dans le sens où on a on
a fait un début de match médiocre on va
dire on était à
tous deux une semble notamment 10 en
début de match on n'arrivait pas à
marquer leur gardien fait une par tasse
mais magnifique défensivement on a du
mal à se mettre en route
derrière on a réussi à réduire le score
juste avant la mi temps
gros début de deuxième et à partir de là
avec le public aujourd'hui
on ya cru jusqu'au bout donc il ya un
minimum de déception sur la fin parce
que voilà un pitch hijra la toute
dernière mais vu le début de match c'est
mérité pour les deux équipes c'est un
super match ce qui nous a permis de
remonter cet écart
ça n'a été que l'application des
consignes de début de match donc je
trouve ça quand même assez frustrant mon
point de vue d'entraîneur de
de donner 10 buts comme ça de crédit à
un adversaire direct au classement royer
plaisir sont toujours premiers ex-aequo
avec un point d'avancé sur le troisième
les plaisirs war second dimanche
prochain la métropolitaine des
transports des nouvelles du vendée globe
deux immigrés sont encore en course pour
ce tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale louis burton et éric bellion ont
eu quelques soucis techniques avec leurs
bateaux mais ils ont réussi à passer le
cap de bonne espérance
le novice b lyon est pour le moment à la
17e place du classement à près de dix
mille kilomètres des premiers on regarde
la séquence qu'il a enregistré ce
week-end la nuit a été musclé mais j'ai
eu il pourrait précéder la vie n'est pas
en bon marin c'est
je commence à sourire parce que ça fait
peur se régalant prête et
la confiance les vagues sont grosses
sommes à un peu plus populaire un peu
plus près des leaders on retrouve leur
envol ita à louis burton le navigateur
est toujours installé à la 11e place du
classement sur son imoca bureau vallée
mais le skipper ne fait pas la course
seul des baleines sont venus lui tenir
compagnie pendant son périple on regarde
la séquence enregistrée par louis burton
une bonne
jean-luc quoi
aussi proche
sa cure en développement bush pour me
dire que comme ça ça doit faire
plusieurs tonnes sur le vif la baleine
et le jeu petit skipper qui sont dans
leurs petits
yao bien petit des images du vendée
globe toujours aussi spectaculaire
hameau de boxe grosse déception pour le
verrez roi ahmed el moussaoui le sportif
chinois de 26 ans n'a pas réussi à
remporter le titre vacant de champion
d'europe ebu des poids welters opposé à
l'espagnol ceferino rodriguez ce
vendredi à las palmas en espagne el
moussaoui a dû concéder la défaite aux
points face à l'ibérique alors qu'il
avait réussi à mettre au sol son
adversaire au début du 12e round le
boxeur saint quentinois déjà annoncé
vouloir continuer sa carrière mais qu'il
avait besoin de quelques semaines pour
rebondir après cette contre performance
lui aussi il ira au combat le 2 janvier
prochain à livigno attristant couëdel va
tenter de mettre ko les dunes à
l'occasion du dakar 2010 7,1 compétition
créée en 1978 organisée pour la neuvième
année consécutive en amérique du sud et
traversera la bolivie et l'argentine
nous avons rencontré ce passionné
d'automobile a dans son garage nous
sommes à mézy sur seine dans les
yvelines je suis avec triste au cou et
dell qui va participer au dakar pour la
troisième fois cette année
le compte à rebours est lancé tristan
codel on va peut-être un petit peu plus
vous connaître dans cette interview est
ce que vous pouvez vous vous présenter
alors je me prénomme tristan
effectivement j'ai la chance de à la
fois de pouvoir assouvir ma passion de
l'automobile et notamment dans la
compétition du dakar j'ai l'opportunité
de faire du rallye du circuit mais le
rallye raid occupe une place
particulière dans mon coeur que belles
et grandes étendues le désert et
toujours pour moi était quelque chose de
très attractif donc j'ai la chance
effectivement cette année de repartir
sur le dakar pourquoi repartir puisque
il y a deux ans même équipage même
automobile même pays puisque finalement
nous étions partis aussi de buenos aires
est effectivement va se relancer dans
l'aventuré cette année
est ce que vous avez appris peut-être
des erreurs du passé je crois que ça ne
s'était pas très bien passé
la dé la foi alors en fait ça s'était
bien passé dans l'entente sur le team en
revanche mécaniquement à notre auto
avait décidé de jouer des tours donc
effectivement on est entre guillemets on
pense tous les deux pas rester
suffisamment longtemps dans l'aventuré
puisqu'on a eu un abandon assez tôt dans
la course
et effectivement on a appris beaucoup de
choses à la fois sur la gestion de
l'épreuve mais aussi sur les
aménagements qui était nécessaire de
faire sur notre dos est-ce-qu'il recette
miracle pour finir le dakar ou leur
portée même alors c'est tout l'enjeu
dans le cadre d'un amateur comme nous
sommes l'objectif est pas forcément
d'avoir une place au classement
véritablement nous ce qu'on cherche à
faire et on a une approche un peu
particulière avec mon coéquipier c'est
qu'on souhaite finir le dakar est prouvé
qu'en 2017
il est possible de finir un dakar sans
avoir de mécano puisque notre équipage a
la particularité d'être sans assistance
c'est à dire que le soir quand on arrive
au bivouac qu'il soit 22 heures ou 4
heures du matin il faut reconditionnés
nous mêmes notre automobile de manière à
pouvoir repartir le lendemain on va
parler de vos objectifs sur ce dakar
vous allez peut-être trop porter la
course pour la ramener dans les yvelines
tout ça est compliqué alors très
honnêtement la course du courage
peut-être la course de l'ingéniosité
pour arriver au bout peut-être en vain
je doute qu'on vienne ennuyer lycée
bastien loeb ni peterhansel d'abord
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes outils
pour travailler une fois de plus ils ont
passé une équipe d'usiné
vous avez une dizaine de mécano dans le
team qui varient reconditionnés l'auto
en permanence et puis sont des gens qui
sont hyper entraînés mois en parallèle
de ça on a une société on travaille
toute l'année on a eu beau jeu vous les
dix 10 jours entre guillemets peaufiner
notre auto donc c'est pas le même niveau
de préparation entre un professionnel en
amateur donc on n'a pas les mêmes
objectifs notre objectif réellement est
de réussir à prouver qu'on peut faire le
dakar aujourd'hui le terminus en mécano
être au bout bien sûr et puis vivre une
belle aventure puisque finalement ça
ressemble un petit peu une aventure dans
une société il ya des enjeux des
objectifs on se bat on se bat au
quotidien chaque heure chaque minute et
c'est un peu à l'image de ce qu'on fait
dans une petite structure on insulte
avec cette salariée en permanence voilà
c'est ce challenge se renouveler trouver
des solutions voilà c'est ce qu'ont fait
typiquement et c'est un peu d'une
certaine heure une extrapolation de ce
qu'on vit avec mon associé depuis
quelques années maintenant
c'est noté tristan merci beaucoup en
tout cas nous avoir accueillis dans
votre garage ici à mézy-sur-seine besoin
d'une interview vous
je rappelle aux téléspectateurs le dakar
ça commence le 2 janvier la section
cheerleaders l'équipe de football
américain des templiers d'elancourt
prend l'accent russe victoria borodina
vient de rejoindre la structure pour
devenir coach adjointe elle aidera la
section à s'améliorer dans toutes les
techniques de portée nous l'avons
rencontré à l'occasion de son premier
entraînement sur une feuille pour le
montage je m'appelle victoria ball arena
je suis russe victoria 27 ans la
nouvelle coach adjointe des cheerleaders
des templiers d'elancourt la russe
domicilié à montfort l'amaury depuis
quelques semaines a été embauchée suite
à une annonce postée par les dirigeants
sur facebook
la sportive espère transmettre son
expérience à ce club créé en 2012 à ces
tueries des bénévoles et il
j'ai commencé le chili le 18 ans j'ai
fais une équipe avec ma meilleure amie
dans notre université et ensuite j'ai
intégré des clubs de cheerleading
c'est vraiment une grande étape pour moi
d'avoir été le seul buteur en russie et
maintenant d'aider cette équipe de
france
la cheerleader travaillera en binôme
avec lorie fournier coach dans la
structure depuis trois ans je suis plus
spécialisés dans le cheer dancing donc
tout ce qui va être chorégraphie et c
est s est vrai qu'elle a vraiment des
bonnes bases en cheerleading purée en
termes de stunt et c'est donc elle va
elle va nous apporter vraiment ce qui
nous manquait pour la section alors les
stones en fait ça va être les porter ça
va être les pyramides ce genre de choses
donc intenté ya des choses un peu
gymnastique pour sa première séance
d'entraînement ce lundi 28 novembre
victoria dirigé dix filles âgées de 15 à
24 ans elle nous a un peu aidé à revoir
les bases qui au final
était pas plus mal parce que on avait
pris quelques mauvaises habitudes je
suis fly donc je suis en haut je me fais
porter en fait et elle m'a appris plus
gagner enfin comment bien gainer comment
bien se tenir sur les portes et la
nouvelle coach désormais deux mois pour
peaufiner les porter en vue de la saison
de football américain qui débutera le 21
janvier prochain domicile pour les
templiers d'elancourt termine ce
magazine par un record l'eau
franco-cubain andy cabreira avila a
réussi ce vendredi à la piscine de saint
cyr l'école un exploit hors du commun
l'occasion du téléthon
le sportif a nagé pendant 12 heures en
apnée en réalisant une respiration à
chaque longueur
au total il aura nager près de 29
kilomètres pendant son défi encore sera
communiquée au guinness book dans les
prochains jours andy cabreira nous livre
son secret pour réussir un tel exploit
les pièges à vitesse et surtout aller
trop vite on est témoin de gaspiller de
l'énergie mais aussi à beaucoup de
choses qui peut arriver par l'iphone par
exemple on s'est dit c'est d'être
rapidement c'est pour ça qu'ils
m'arrêtent les dix minutes tout bois et
il ya les craintes surtout les craintes
après avec la foule kelly allez allez
allez on peut aller plus vite qu'ils ont
l'habitude de faire et pour avoir des
crampes fatigués mais sinon pour le
reste il faut gérer son effort à
élémentale bénéficie bien sûr
un record qu'il ne faudra évidemment pas
tenté à la piscine sans entraînement
spécifique
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
fil 78
[Musique]